[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
before we start the video i just wanted
to mention that only 21
of you are subscribed so if you enjoy
the content please consider subscribing
to support the channel
in this video we're going to be
discussing the five most powerful spells
and abilities of he who shall not be
named otherwise known as lord voldemort
voldemort is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful if not
the most powerful dark wizard in the
entire harry potter universe
born tom marvolo riddle in 1926
voldemort began attending hogwarts in
and was sorted into none other than
southern house
dumbledore and voldemort are thought to
possess fairly equal power
dumbledore edges him out just a little
with the exception that
one practices magic for good and the
other practices it
for evil because magic exists on both
sides
light and dark it means that the magic
voldemort and dumbledore wield
on a regular basis varies quite a bit
each side boasts its own benefits
even at a young age voldemort proved
himself to be a magical prodigy
as he was able to utilize and control
magic without the use of a wand
he had the power to move objects with
his mind to communicate with and control
animals
and even inflict harm on those who
opposed or annoyed him
which left even dumbledore astonished he
performed feats of magic thought
impossible
and his magical accomplishments eclipsed
and dwarfed
those of any dark wizard before him with
the exception of only gaelic grindelwald
he puts it best himself i have
experimented
i have pushed the boundaries of magic
further perhaps than they have ever been
pushed
so we know that he's powerful and that
he was an extremely talented wizard
but what exactly are his most powerful
abilities
let's take a look number five
unsupported flight
and then harry saw him voldemort was
flying like smoke on the wind
without broomstick or thestral to hold
him his snake-like face gleaming out of
the blackness
his white fingers raising his wand again
jk rowling is reported to have stated
that
all wizards have the power of flight
innately but the vast vast majority
needed broom to achieve it in
voldemort's case he was so focused and
powerful
that he was able to channel the power to
fly unsupported harnessing the energy
through himself
rather than the broom this achievement
is a sign of a truly powerful witch or
wizard
and meant that you were in seriously hot
water if voldemort was chasing after you
number four legitimacy the mind is not a
book
to be opened at will and examined at
leisure thoughts are not etched on the
inside of skulls
to be perused by any invader the mind is
a complex and many layered thing
potter or at least most minds are it is
true
however that those who have mastered
legitimacy are able
under certain conditions to delve into
the minds of their victims
and to interpret their findings
correctly legitimacy is essentially the
art of magically navigating through
someone's mind
it's rather invasive and allows you to
see into people's minds and read their
thoughts
while this ability is used by many other
witches and wizards and is not unique to
voldemort by any means
voldemort has certainly proven himself
to be a master at it
voldemort mastered legitimacy during his
time at school
entirely determined to become more
skilled at it than any other witch or
wizard
to have ever lived using his skill in
legitimacy
voldemort could almost always tell who
was lying to him and often knew what you
were thinking
before you uttered a word only
incredibly good liars like severus snape
and assisted malfoy were able to lie to
voldemort successfully
the counter diligency is occlumency
which is the practice of magically
closing one's mind
against legitimacy with the exception of
severus snape and dumbledore
voldemort was basically able to access
anyone's mind if he so desired
snape and dumbledore on the other hand
are safe due to their mastery and
occlumency
snape acts as a double agent in the
books and films but is still able to
deceive lord voldemort
despite frequent interaction and i don't
think that this is a shot at voldemort's
abilities
as a legitimate as he was the best at it
but more of a testament to snape's
impressive ability
to perform occlumency a basic level
oklahomans is simply able to clear their
mind in the event of a mind infiltration
while a master occupant is able to
change their thought patterns
in order to further confuse the
legitimates number three
avada kadavra there was a flash of
blinding green light
and a rushing sound as though a vast
invisible something was soaring through
the air
instantaneously the spider rolled over
onto its back
unmarked but unmistakably dead avada
kadavra aka the killing curse
is a favorite of many dark witches and
wizards and is one of the three
unforgivable curses
perhaps the worst vada kadavra's purpose
is simple
it causes the victim to instantly die if
you want to kill your victim
then this is the spell to use lord
voldemort is a known proponent of the
spell
which creates a blindingly intense green
bolt of light right before the victim
simply drops dead there are two theories
for how they die
the first claiming the victim's internal
organs cease to function
after being struck and the second
claiming that the soul of the victim
is magically ripped from their body the
only known counter-spell to avada
kadavra
is sacrificial protection which was most
notably used by lily potter
and uses the power of love the name of
vada kadavra
comes from the word abracadabra which
means let the thing
be destroyed avada kedavra is used very
often in the books and films
most notably by voldemort on harry
potter's parents and by snape on
dumbledore
though there is no way to block avada
kedavra effectively you can move objects
in the way of the green jet of light
that it produces
avada cadaver is powerful but it's
really not that special
and i think that if you want to cause
damage on a larger scale
there are some better options that's why
it isn't higher on the list number two
fiend fire it was not normal fire crab
had used a curse of which harry had no
knowledge
as they turned a corner the flames
chased them as though they were alive
sentient intent upon killing them now
the fire was mutating
forming a gigantic pack of fiery beasts
flaming serpents
chimeras and dragons rose and fell and
rose again
and the decorators of centuries on which
they were feeding was thrown up in the
air
to their fanged mouths tossing high on
clawed feet
before being consumed by the inferno
fiendfire is one of
the most powerful spells in harry potter
period
voldemort is known proponent of the
spell and he can be seen using it
against dumbledore
in the epic jewel in the ministry atrium
fiend fire produces enchanted
flames of an enormous scale that
essentially destroy anything in its path
often taking the form of gigantic fiery
beasts
true to voldemort's affinity for snakes
voldemort's own fiend fire takes the
shape of a gigantic
fiery serpent vienfire is extremely
advanced dark magic
and is also one of only a few known ways
to destroy a horcrux
number one creating horcruxes and
immortality
a tamper with the deepest mysteries the
source of life
the essence of self only if prepared for
consequences
of the most extreme and dangerous kind a
horcrux is an object in which a dark
witch or wizard
imparts a piece of their soul in order
to achieve immortality
a horcrux can only be created after
committing an act of murder
and is considered to be the most
terrible form of dark magic
only two known wizards are known to have
created them the first being herpa de
fowl
who created a single horcrux and the
second being voldemort
who successfully created seven the truly
sinister component of creating a horcrux
and one of the reasons that it's an
untouched area of magic
is that in order to produce one you must
murder someone
charms and jinxers are often put in
place to further protect horcruxes
after they're created and the appeal of
them is that if your main physical form
is destroyed
your soul and existence lives on in
these objects
given that voldemort is the most
infamous wizard to use horcruxes
and that it is such powerful magic i
think that it deserves a top
spot on this list and with the list
completed
we've still only really scratched the
surface of what voldemort is capable of
honorable mentions include
transfiguration possession
spell creation the cruciatus curse
potion making
and creating the inferi what do you guys
think do you agree with this list
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you